the original inspiration behind the dog  night trilogy and particularly Batman  Begins it was about taking this beloved  character and recontextualizing the  character setting this extraordinary  figure in an Ordinary World or a  seemingly Ordinary World and so for me  it was much more about creating a  recognizably real scenario that the  extraordinary figure of Batman could  exist in and addressing the origins of  that the origin story which hadn't been  told in films before and so we were able  to really look at that Gap in pop  culture and say okay what if we try to  ground this and really explain how this  might happen in a real world scenario  that was always the jumping off point  for the tone of the film